yo what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 47 of the game
programming so yesterday we took an
awesome look finishing up the King Jonas
right and today we're gonna take a
different look at rendering it alright
so the way that we're currently
rendering it and I mean you guys aren't
blind you can see this [ __ ] we're
rendering it using basically what I like
to call the quad render I just made that
up from the spot I don't recall that but
um we're we're sort of rendering for
different parts of it for quarters if
you will of the actual player and of
course together they make up the yeah
they make up the player alright four
quarters equals one so you can see here
that the FPS drop isn't substantial in
fact it's pretty much non-existent right
we're not rendering too much here we're
not even rendering that many pixels to
begin with but we've got like a good
deal going on here alright so what we
want to do next is render in one it
would just just in one go
alright so currently we've got you know
this render player method being called
four times now why is that the reason
that's happening is because out out out
tiles I guess our sprites are sixteen by
sixteen if we go into sprite you can see
that the player zero want to increase
price best sides is set to 16 that means
that the sprite is 16 times 16 16 by 16
that's how many pixels are there now if
we beef that up to 32 by 32 it's going
to encapsulate every single sprite in
one go okay okay okay okay
glad you guys get that sorry public
whoops
public static sprite play oh I'm just
gonna call play cuz this is just all in
one go equals new sprite now here I want
to put 32 and then over here now this is
where it gets this is where it gets
interesting cuz um because you guys
might not um you might not get this and
this is where a lot of bugs I'm sure are
gonna happen so let me just open up my
my textures open with paint.net alright
here we go
so King sure know right now such a boss
sprite it's it's located right we
counted this last episode it's located
at and down this is this is the tenth
tile downwards this is the tenth sprite
on the y-axis right this this little
beginning here now that's when we're
dealing with sixteen size price which is
currently which was calling the size of
each cell is H cell is 16 by 16 pixels
now what if we start on a 32 by 32 right
because this is remember the size that
we're using now is 32 and if you
actually look in the code what it does
is this x and y which tells out our game
the location of the sprite that's
getting multiplied by size so if the
size is in 16 but it's 32 it's gonna go
down by 32 that's very important all
right get that get that in your head
right now we're not counting down let me
just get my little selector thingy we're
not counting down this much anymore 1 2
or rather 0 1 2 3 4 we're going 1 0 1
oops and take that 0 1 2 3 4 and there
we go 5 this is the 5th sprite down if
we're dealing in 32 pixel nerd alright
very important that is why the number
that we put here
well it'll be 0 here but the number that
we put here is not 10 like it is in the
other ones but it's essentially half of
that and the reason it's half of that 5
we actually counted that but also
because it's gonna be it's gonna be
since this gets doubled the size gets
doubled this gets hard to convert to
compensate for it if you guys need even
more help understanding that think of it
this way we're trying to find the pixel
from where we start the sprite on the y
axis if you multiply 16 by 10
that hell happened that honestly what
happened that 16 times 10 160 right
that's cool
now if the sizes lock to 32 then we go
32 times 5 and it's equal to the same to
same number all right that's how it
works if we need to increase the size we
need to diminish this little thing here
to compensate for that I guess it's
another little way of explaining it and
obviously it's going to use our standard
sprite sheet dark tiles all right there
you go so now we've got the play up
great if we go into this load thing
cause I don't actually remember if we
actually finished dealing with this in
this little dirty thingy so it loads all
right it's gonna Lord as for size it's
going to make pixels equal but no this
is I think this is compatible let's go
back into they the the screen cloth
though so this great job colossi just
wrong on one more time so we can see
what the game looks like this is what
the game looks like I look exactly the
same actually but this is what the game
looks like with four sprites being
rendered and we're running at about 3.5
thousand fps 3600 will give it
okay so render player currently we don't
in 16 sighs let's just get rid of that
and type of 32 instead right so 32 32
and - literature and time feature and
it's probably about it mmm all right and
then we'll go over here and in sprite
sorry in player played up Java we have
this surprised player one will get rid
of all these just like that now we'll
leave these here we could have actually
just made them part of this actually but
you know what screw it we'll leave these
here but we'll change this to describe
our player and of course sprite die play
if I control click is our thirty two
sides prior so let's go back to player
dot Java that looks pretty good actually
let's test that out see what we get and
look at that blam we've got a 32 side
sprite rendering and it's running get
out who the same speed all right now
that's exactly why I wanted to prove to
you guys that rendering things four
times in my game
might be running like 2% faster but just
chilled out that not even 2% more like
0.5% faster but anyway the thing is for
those of you who are thinking that
rendering something four times would be
slow not not cuz in theory it's
rendering the same amount of pixels okay
yep good now let's hear this [ __ ]
and put in on X minus 16 and y minus n
now 16 is um obviously half of the size
of the player so what sort of fun calm
setting for that and drawing King sure
right in the middle so yeah that's how
we do 32 size rendering of sprites
pretty simple now the place where 32
size rendering actually gets bit more
advanced is in collision detection okay
but um we'll do that later anyway I hope
you guys enjoyed this episode of game
programming if you did that like button
is conveniently located right below the
video and that's about it yeah okay I'll
see you guys tomorrow with the sprite
animation play guys bye
you